so
my name is samad i run ct laundry
services we're cleaning service in ghana
accra
i have been doing this for close to nine
years now today i'll be showing you how
to clean a persian rag
this rag has never been cleaned before
the rag is located in their dining area
it had multiple stains on it food stains
coffee spillage
drain soda everything you could mention
it has about 20 years of death sitting
in it
so first of all you give it a good rinse
in the beginning
the water is always cold if you use hot
water it may shrink the fabric or
destroy the fabric you only use hot
water in some cases where you're
treating a particular stain
there's shampoo in a watering can you
can't use just any soap for cleaning
rugs it's a mixture of shampoo the stain
removers and then water so usually when
you apply the shampoo you allow it to
sit for about five to ten minutes then
you know it's gone really deep into the
fibers
the patient rug is usually made of i
believe it's silk so this rug i'm not
sure of the exact cost but it should
cost between eight hundred to a thousand
dollars
so after putting a shampoo then you
scrub with a scrubber
or a buffer some people call it a buffer
but i call it a scrubber
so the buffer
basically
agitates the debts and helps get all the
debt out of the rug
so i scrub all around the rug scrub
scrub give it a good old scrub to get
most of the dead out
there's a brush so there are two types
of brush the hard brush and then the
soft brush so the type of rug will
determine which brush you use for this
one we use the hard brush
some rugs are handmade you can't use the
hard brush you're going to destroy the
fabric of the rug but with this type it
can handle the hard brush
it's not handmade some parts are
handmade like the fringe parts
you have to scrape the water off to get
the first scrubbing session of the dead
out so i use a squeegee or should i see
a scraper a shovel scraper i got someone
to make for me over here
if you
pay attention to my type of scraper you
see how it gathers most of the depth and
pushes all the water away
so the pressure washer helps losing more
debt in a rug
pressure washing a rag alone cannot get
all the debt out you need a shampoo to
help do its magic it's not a one
procedure thing
so i gave it a good old rinse with a
squeegee
then we flipped it to the back
it's important to clean the work area so
the depth doesn't come back into the rug
then you can continue with working
the back side will also require putting
shampoo on it
it's the same procedure just that that
[ __ ] doesn't take as long as the top
side because usually the dirt is trapped
more on the top side than the back side
when you clean the back some of the dead
somehow goes back to the top part so you
have to flip it up and redo the whole
process again
so
scrub scrub scrub
eventually you realize the water becomes
clear so once it gets clear you know
your grag is clean now
patient rugs are not too delicate if i
may say there are different types of
patient rugs some require very close
attention to cleaning but some will
require the normal cleaning procedure
this one needed
extra care because because of the
fringes especially if you're not careful
the fringes are just going to come out
so you manually have to apply the
shampoo
with the chemicals onto the fringes then
you manually scrub
i can use any brush to clean the fringes
any hard brush it has to be a hard brush
because you're dealing with years of
depth you need a hard brush to be able
to scrub all that out
then i use the power washer to blow the
depth out of it
so i am using a wet vacuum to vacuum
most of the water out of the rack i
repeat the process like twice i'm able
to get at least 80 to 90 percent of the
water out of the rug before i leave it
out to try
i see some people use the centrifuge
machine where it spins all the water out
i believe those who use that machine
don't have very good weather over there
in my country the sun is always out so
it helps dry the rocks quickly
it came out great the client was very
satisfied the original colors were
restored as well i had no idea how the
original colors look like you're unable
to tell how originally it looks like so
you're done cleaning
it's usually dead sitting in there for
years that makes it heavily swell it's
best to have a vacuum in your household
where once in a while you vacuum all the
debt out of your rug
[Music]
a rug like this can be cleaned every
half a year
you